hello welcome to another episode of not
too deep i'm your host
grace helbig berry very excited
to have lydia hearst joining us for
today's episode she's a model
she's an actress she's a horror film
enthusiast and enthusiast isn't even the
most enthusiastic word i can use to
describe
her deep love and appreciation for the
horror genre hear all about how she got
started in modeling
how she made the jump to acting about
her most recent lifetime movie psycho
sister-in-law
and all of the wild steps it took for
her to get into that role she came from
having a major accident on set to having
to learn how to use her brain
again get all of her cognitive functions
back in working order
to be able to play a psycho
sister-in-law on a lifetime movie i mean
her story is
insane she's also married to chris
hardwick we talk about how their love
story began
and um the fact that their house is
probably haunted
you'll enjoy this episode because i
really did i'm not too deep with lydia
hurst
[Music]
lydia thank you so much for being here i
am so excited to talk to you because i
think you have such
an interesting hybrid life
career situation going on and i'm
fascinated by it
uh my first question i ask people that i
usually have
a lot of different descriptors to
their their work how do you describe
what you do who you are like let's say
an alien came down how would you
introduce yourself
oh gosh um i don't i don't
know i think there's a lot of
preconceived notions
as to who i am as a person just
based on like stereotypes or my name
but realistically i would say
i'm pretty down to earth more like a
country girl who's weird and eccentric
and loves horror
love that yeah because you're you're a
model
you're an actress you're uh really into
horror and thriller
which usually like model and that don't
necessarily go together
right yes yeah i was not exactly the
most popular model
back in the day around all the other
models i don't think any of them really
got me at all so it's pretty much me and
my cat for a long time
that's great that's why animals are
wonderful now did you always have an
affinity to like
horror and thriller genres okay how
about that i'm obsessed with it like i i
remember i think
i saw army of darkness for the first
time in like kindergarten or first grade
and i was obsessed and that's pretty
much been it
that's nice and now so you are from you
know a very notable
family so growing up for you i'm curious
because you were born in connecticut is
that right
it was yeah i grew up in connecticut
actually okay and so what was
life like how did you get into modeling
how did like you get into the
entertainment world
um i mean for me growing up
seemed normal i guess yeah um like i
grew up in a very small town
in connecticut which i loved i went to
public school which was so much fun
hell yeah and it seemed really normal
but my mom at the same time she was
working on a lot of john waters movies
so i did kind of bounce back and forth
between connecticut and baltimore
visiting the sets of those and it was
just
they were so amazing like i remember
i was in kindergarten when she did
crybaby
and like then like johnny depp was in
the movie and he was dating winona ryder
at the time and i'd also just be
beetlejuice where she played lydia so
for me that was like a huge
deal um and it just and the costumes the
sets the music
it was so cool i was just enamored by it
and i knew that that
was a world that i wanted to be in my
parents kept trying to convince me to
stay in school and become a lawyer
a little different of a route yeah like
when i was in high school
my parents finally were like okay you
know if you want
to try to work in fashion and
entertainment we'll take you on a couple
meetings to agencies and just
see what happens yeah so they finally
drove me into the city and i remember i
went to
img elite and ford models
all of them turned me down which must
have been just such a rewarding
experience
yes it felt awesome yeah but it was
really weird because they were like well
you have a really
cool interesting face you look sort of
like an alien
but you're really short so no
because i'm only about five six like i
think it's printed everywhere on all
sorts of different heights because the
modeling agencies
lied a lot but i'm only like five six
maybe five
six and a half okay so i'm not tall or
well i'm
tall but not tall for a model um and
then i remember
the last meeting i was in i was at ford
models
and they turned me down and then i was
leaving the building
getting on the elevator and this
exquisitely
beautiful older woman stepped off the
elevator and just sort of eyed me up and
down
and then gracefully strutted down the
hallway and i was just you know i was
probably 16 at the time and just kind of
hopped on the elevator and was like
well i guess that's that and by the time
i hit
the lobby the assistant to the head of
the agency
had run all the way down the stairs and
had a contract in hand and was like
we'd like to sign you because i guess
the woman went in
and looked at all the composites on the
wall and was like well where's where's
that girl that i just saw
getting on the elevator i want her well
i still don't
know who she was she was just some sort
of
angel and yeah she was like a fashion
ghost
that came in that you never saw again
some apparition that's right
yeah that's like a scene from a movie
that all of a sudden the assistant comes
running with a contract for you as
you're walking out the door
well it sounds like an exciting start
but then even after i signed the
contract
it was i mean it was insane because i
would go to castings and you know
i don't know what people call them now
but back in the day we call them cattle
calls
so yeah but just such a glamorous name
there'd be like 200 beautiful girls
standing in a line waiting to
cycle through a room to like either do a
runway show or shoot a campaign
and because i was so petite
um literally like i remember there was
this french designer
who took out a tape measure and measured
how tall i was and then like burst out
laughing and i was constantly kicked out
of auditions and castings and rooms
and i wasn't getting anything i had no
shot to do anything
and then i had this one casting where
i went and i was sitting in sort of the
lobby area and someone took my
portfolio at the time which was
practically like my high school yearbook
like i didn't have
any photos yeah yeah and they took these
pictures back which were really sad
photos i
never even saw the person i was supposed
to meet with
and then i got sent home so i thought
well that's
it i guess i can't really do anything
it's over i guess
and a week later i got a phone call
that i needed to take the train into the
city
like six a.m the next morning and i had
to be in milk studios first thing
and then i was shooting italian vogue
with stephen myself oh my god and then
the next thing i know
a couple months later the magazine came
out and i was on the cover
and then it was really interesting
though because all the people who
laughed me out of casting rooms and
turned me down
and literally shunned me and pushed me
away suddenly we're like oh i i get it
but i'm still the same person i was back
then now just one person took my photo
which you
a genius and he's a fashion god but
really wow
that's so it because how old are you at
the time that this is happening
uh i was about 16. that's
so much for a 16 year old right process
and i'm sure that must have been the
craziest experience
because it was very surreal well it's
also i
i went i'm from new jersey and i like
when i was 18
also tried to dabble a little bit in
modeling because i'm i'm tall and it's
wild because like you said that industry
wants you to be the tallest thing in the
universe and then
when you get into the acting world you
have to
be the smallest thing ever and it's just
such a
like contradiction of itself but the
so you're doing this you're 16 you shoot
for italian vogue it's a whirlwind so
does the modeling career kind of take
off from there
it did it took off on virtually
overnight so i shot that
end of it like right after thanksgiving
um
in 2003 so i guess it was 17 at that
time finally
and um it came out in april 2004
and then the next thing i knew the
morning after it came out my phone
started blowing up and i was on the
first flight
overseas to do all the runway shows and
do everything
and i was never known as like a show
girl
but i was extremely fortunate because i
was so petite
carl lagerfeld sort of took me under his
wing
and he thought it was so funny how small
i was
that during every show that i did for
him he would place me
between the two tallest models that he
had just because he thought it was
really funny
so you become this like object
of comedy in a way in this modern world
which i mean god bless because i feel
like all of
that sort of like bizarre weird
criticism
it's either gonna make you or break you
especially for a teenager like i'm sure
you develop such a thick skin in that
world
you you have to i mean i even remember
when i was first rejected from all the
agencies my parents took me
to the wall and showed me all those
composites of like
the most beautiful women i've ever seen
and my mom
was very clear where she was like these
are all the girls that they represent
and then to the right of that was like a
much smaller wall that had
three maybe four images on it and she
goes
these are the ones who've made it there
are hundreds of agencies
in hundreds of cities across the globe
like this
and i was like wow that's reality and
that is
crazy but at that moment i was like and
i'm gonna make it
like i'm gonna do it and again somehow
the fates were in my favor
and i made it that's so cool i mean
kudos to your mom for giving you a
little bit of a reality check to be like
i'm gonna let you down before you get
let down by this industry a little bit
i need tough luck also the modeling
world and
i think it's you you seem like you have
a great sense of humor which i'm sure
helps in that world because it can be uh
degrading a little bit of people just
like
scrutinizing every inch of your person
constantly
uh yeah were there any particular
shoots or auditions that you went on
that stood out that were like just
so bonkers to you i mean i'm sure this
stuff that you've experienced in the
industry
would blow anyone's mind so i feel free
to pick and choose whatever
you know i don't really know i never
have taken
anything too seriously like i always
kind of try to have fun like even that
first photo shoot
that i did like i i had no idea how
serious it was right like i was so green
and so new to the industry
i obviously read vogue and scene images
but i didn't know
what a big deal it was so as i was
getting my hair and makeup done and
everyone's sort of like
this is very serious you need to focus
like a lot of the shots were just like
running and jumping
and trying to be serious while like you
know you're flailing your arms around
and
i'm just a goofball so i like one and
also my feet i'm a size
five and the entire time that i was
working in fashion they were handing me
a size nine and a half ten shoes
so i look like an idiot i can barely
walk in these things and i'm having to
literally do gymnastics in these
giant you know shoes and i fell on my
butt and just burst out laughing and
that literally
i sort of think that's what sealed the
deal for everything in fashion because
then
stephen who was very stoic suddenly sort
of
broke that character and started
laughing and we became friends after
that
so it's so nice no that's great because
i feel like you can look at a fashion
magazine two ways you can look at it in
a very
serious high art sort of frame of mind
or you can look at it and realize like
these women are contorting their bodies
in the most hilarious ways
yeah we're supposed to say wow that's
high fashion which i i get but it also
you have to laugh at some of these
things it's absolutely incredibly
ridiculous yeah
now you've gone from this like high
fashion world and i just saw that you
did a quarantine photo shoot recently
i did yeah yeah what is that like i have
not
yet experienced that but what's it like
having someone on facetime
shooting like glamorous photos of you it
was
it was interesting like it was a lot of
fun though
um because a photographer was a friend
of mine so he was back
in new york and then he was facetiming
with chris
and so chris was sort of like holding
the cell phone
and i was just wearing my own stuff i
did my own hair makeup and just sort of
splashing around the pool trying to be
like
is this sexy i don't care
like i don't consider myself sexy
so doing shoots like that like i always
like you might manage to get
one snap that like looks cool or
fashionable but then the rest i'm
usually just like laughing my ass off
being like i don't
know what i'm doing like this right like
you want me to run around
and scream bloody murder
it seems like a lot of guess and
checking that it's like let's see if
this works is that no
not that okay we'll try a different one
but i i think
i find it interesting because you know
so many people are very quick to write
off like the fashion world and to write
off the modeling world and see it as
very just like narcissistic or whatever
but the you know shows like america's
next top model i think showed
the depth of it and like the diligence
and the hard work
in a way i mean those they definitely in
those shows i think
hype it up for the cameras too yeah
i even i was a mentor on the face for
one season and it was fun
and i loved all the girls but like
there's definitely an element where they
they build it up and it's a little bit
more extreme than it is
in reality i mean i i learned how to
sort of
pull myself together and do hair makeup
from being on set
and you know when i did fashion for
years
i had no idea how to dress myself like
the standard
wardrobe used to be you were a blank
canvas you wore
jeans and a black tank top and you did
not show up anywhere
in anything else and if you did you were
sent home and that was disgraceful but
now i look at photos and these
young women are going to castings and
like couture ensembles i'm like
what what is that i'm still trying to
figure out how to put an outfit together
right well it's i think it's also
interesting too because there's been
this sort of like
renaissance or something with the gigi
hadids and the you know the kendall
genders where like they want
models to have a presence a personality
a brand around them
it's not just like a bunch of human
hangers walking down
a runway show it feels like right
they're encouraging and rewarding
people being themselves a little bit
more um
do you have any like i started yeah i'm
sure so it must be kind of liberating to
like actually be yourself a little bit
more
it is but it's still it's weird though
because when i
started like i did it's fun
because i'm always changing my hair and
my makeup
and like it's sort of fun because when i
change all those things
my face sort of changes too where it's
like different
aspects of it get sort of highlighted
where
i kind of look like a totally different
person depending on what i'm wearing and
how my makeup is done and what my hair
is with the color and when i started
working it was like you didn't
you weren't doing it to promote yourself
you were doing it
because it was like edgy and cool and it
was still sort of the end of like the
club kid era
um and you know you did the photos but
like no one really knew it was you so it
was almost like a fun little secret to
be like oh my gosh my billboard's in
times square
like my photos in this shop on like
madison avenue how cool is that but like
like so and now it's all about like well
what's the name that goes with the image
and who's this
and i think that might be why in
acting that might be why i don't really
post that much on instagram i'm still
kind of wary of the whole social media
thing i do it good for you
good for you i think that's a
healthy apprehension but i think also
that's why with acting
i tend to go more towards character
roles
where half the time or more than half
the time i either don't
look at all like me and i get really
like gritty and disgusting looking yeah
a different personality than playing
like the classic heroine and
yeah that's what i think is so cool so
when was there
like a conscious decision to get into
acting or was that something that just
kind of like a
byproduct opportunity of like being in
the entertainment world
um you know it was something that i knew
i always wanted to do
and i think you know i don't even know
how exactly it happened but i just
remember one day i was in my apartment
in new york and i woke up and i was like
i you know i just sort of had this
realization where i was like i
hate new york city you know it's a great
city to visit but
like i never felt at home there yeah and
so unless i was going
to and from set i really never left my
apartment
um and so one day i just sort of woke up
and was like i
don't like it here i feel like my soul
is dying and i
went down this incredible road and i've
lived a full life and had a full
career an amazing journey but this isn't
where i want to be
so i literally went online booked a
ticket
and packed up my cat in a suitcase and
came out to la and never went back wow
did you put your cat in a suitcase well
no i mean
he was in his carry-on and then i found
the suitcase and came out that way
um okay we're going to take a quick
break when we get back i want to hear
all about because you take on these
roles that are very gritty like you said
very um psychotic for lack of a better
word uh it's speaking of the upcoming
movie i want to hear all about it so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two
things a big thank you for listening to
the podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise
maybe just good or otherwise would be
appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay so speaking of psycho roles
psycho sister-in-law is the newest
lifetime movie
that you have coming out i think by the
time uh oh it's out already august 16th
that came out
it came out august 16th and i guess
thankfully it did really well
so they're gonna do a second showing of
it on my birthday september 19th so i
think they're doing two showings one at
2 p.m
and then one again at 8. that's so
exciting i have so many questions first
of all
you're presented with being in a
lifetime movie
there's all of this stigma and for
better or worse around lifetime movies
what's your how did you approach this
i was really
excited yeah but finally i was supposed
to play
there's a character in the beginning of
the film that sort of has that
classic you know drew barrymore
scream-esque
moment that sets the tone of the movie
and originally i was supposed to be that
character
and i was already over the moon and
excited about doing that and then about
two days before production i get a call
from the director
and he offered me the role of the lead
zara downs wow and two days
before you start this film wow okay and
i
i thought i was gonna have a nervous
breakdown actually because like there
were a lot of reasons because i was so
over the moon excited ecstatic about
doing this because i
lifetime movies are my guilty pleasure
yeah but and this is gonna sound really
weird
i was petrified because i didn't know if
i'd be able to do it
what a lot of people don't know is about
a year and a half ago i was in a
terrible accident on set um the sun
scene gone
horribly wrong my like the prosthetic
that i was wearing saved my life
um my nose instead of going into my
brain ricocheted off the prosthetic
exploded
my skull fractured and my brain swelled
so i spent about a year
living in the dark because i was so
badly concussed i couldn't read i
couldn't watch movies i couldn't play
video games like i couldn't do
anything and then once i sort of healed
from
the original breakage i had to get
reconstructive surgery to kind of put
myself back together like humpty dumpty
so then i had to recover from that
and i was still so badly concussed that
i really only just recently fully
recovered from that
to get full like cognitive abilities and
feel like myself again
so doing that small part i was like yes
i've got it and then when i got the
phone call about doing the lead i
literally was like
i don't i don't know if i can like
handle it i don't know if my brain
will work right yeah you're like
literally and metaphorically i don't
know if my brain will work
yeah and i was just like oh my god like
i i genuinely had
no idea and so i i get off the phone and
i'm like what do i do what do i do and
thank goodness chris
like happened to be walking by at the
time of like me being ecstatic and
starting to have a mental
breakdown being like i don't think i can
do it i don't know what to say like i'm
so petrified
he was like you're fine you can do it
like you've been working so hard and
you've been doing the cognitive
therapies and your brain is working like
i'm telling you your brain's working
that's a good partner to reassure you
that your brain is in fact working
but i i just i was petrified so
i immediately got the script and poor
chris i made him read through the whole
thing with me about
30 times in the 48 hours before the
movie started
wow like i think you might have known
the movie better than i did by the time
i got to set it
amazing and i just you know i
showed up and it was still one of those
things where i was like
oh my god like i love lifetime movies i
don't want to mess it up i have to do
well but like
it's only 48 hours what if i forget the
lines and
i don't know if i fully establish the
voice of the character
and again this is when i'm so grateful
chris was like
look you're not doing a spielberg film
it's
lifetime like you love these movies you
know these movies
i sat with you and read the script 30
times i know you know the dialogue like
you've got this just have fun and it
just sort of
allowed me to kind of breathe
and go for it and let it go um yeah
because you're i mean the part is no
your part is no easy part like
especially all the five scenes
wild and going from yeah getting your
cognitive abilities back to now
playing a psycho sister-in-law is
a little bit of a jump for anyone
so what was the filming process like i
mean to get yourself into that sort of
like
mental space were you doing anything in
particular are we just kind of like
letting yourself free fall into it i
sort of
i let myself free fall into it a bit and
i had a lot of really fun conversations
with the director
where you know he wanted me to play with
it he wanted me to have fun with it and
find out who she was
as we were going along because the
character herself she does she loves her
family she loves the people that are
around her
but at the same time she doesn't love
anybody more than she loves herself
yeah they're always out for that
personal game and she's a hustler
but she wants to reconnect with family
to a degree but she's
a master manipulator at the same time
very fun very juicy
what's the i'm so cause also like
lifetime movies
their guilty pleasure but i was thinking
about this morning that you know we've
grown up with these stories being
so over the top ridiculous right but you
know
these days i don't know if they seem as
ridiculous as they used to
no it's so weird yeah what was the
response like after the first showing of
it
um you know i think people really seems
to like it but it is it's really funny
because
there's one thing um there's a funny
thing that happens in the movie
that i actually do in real life and it's
so dumb where it's like you hear a noise
and the character in those movies are
always like
hello and it's like i and it's
embarrassing i
literally do that almost every day in my
house like i hear a sound it could be
the dog or it could be chris
walking in and i'm like hello i think
he's always like
it's just me a burglar like what i'm
expecting
well okay to make this transition then
speaking of your house
at hearstwick home this uh
you how do you guys describe your style
because it's it's
a lot but it's a thoughtful lot yeah
yeah
i mean as you can see behind me there's
a lot of a lot of stuff going on there's
even
some movie props perfect perfect it
feels like there's
an endless amount of things to look at
yes i mean i think it'd be really easy
to in a sense be classified as hoarders
okay um
because at least you know it's clean so
it's not a mess everywhere but
we do have a lot of stuff um it's kind
of like a victorian
uh a very eclectic bizarre
mishmash of everything okay
a lot of antiques but then occasionally
like a modern twist here and there
i think it's very fun it's very playful
uh
do you guys have ghosts because looking
at the design
yeah it feels like if i were a ghost i
would feel at home
in this situation have you had any
experience
weird moments in this house like when we
first moved in
doors have opened and closed for real
for real yes like literally one time we
just moved into the house we were here
for about a week and a door slammed in
my face
and i just i thought it was chris
playing a weird joke that i didn't get
yeah
that was like across the house and like
in the basement nowhere
anywhere near where i was um and then
there was another night like
we've heard footsteps and voices but
then like no one's
there oh and there was a while that i
thought like obviously someone living in
the walls or the crawl space so like i
had
alarm systems because i was so paranoid
because i was hearing the footsteps from
the voices i have like
all the crawl spaces all the windows all
the doors every little nook and cranny
has like
a surveillance camera and an alarm on it
and gosh
i mean there's nothing so i don't wow
wow
we've definitely caught doors on some of
the cameras opening
he says it's you know maybe an
earthquake and i'm like i don't know
there was no earthquake
so and the door is closed i don't know
that a latch is going to be unlocked and
the door is going to be opened
wow wow i'm getting freaked out just
here
but i mean that it all makes sense
because it says
feel like it almost feels like you guys
have built out your brand
to such a degree that like even the
whole like the house
he refuses to believe there's ghosts i'm
pretty sure of it and like i don't know
how he still says like oh no
it's you know this or that like there's
always some
not really rational explanation but i
remember there was one time a couple
months ago
he was sort of like oh you know there's
no ghosts i don't believe in that
they're not real and literally something
like flew off a shelf and like smashed
onto the floor and he was like
well that's weird oh i don't like that
oh have you guys ever thought about
having like ghost hunters come
to the place and check it out i
definitely have
but again like he doesn't believe in
that stuff so i don't know if you'd be
as open to it as i am right right
well in line with that uh you have a new
project that you announced called with
teeth
yes okay so tell me about this because
you're on this project as both an actor
and an executive producer right okay
what is this
so this is it's sort of a
new like it's a modern retelling of a
classic vampire war
so it's you know they're not twilight
vampires
okay okay they're very they're very dark
they're very twisted
and it's a new it's a new take on how
the legacy
of vampires began and continues
to thrive and survive in a modern era
whoa cool uh and this
hasn't shot yet it hasn't no i believe
we're waiting for the final green light
so if all goes well
we might begin shooting in albuquerque
in october
cool i'm very excited about it
it feel i mean this whole like thriller
genre like you said
is your kind of like bread and butter do
you
it does this go in line with like
doomsday prepping or like zombie
apocalypse prepping like is that
something that you look into
um you know i do have a lot of prep
supplies
okay um i'm not good at like
i'm not good at sort of doing things in
moderation
i guess so it's a good thing i don't
drink or anything like that because i
would just be disastrous
like i i just you know after everything
that happened a few years ago in puerto
rico with the power outages and the food
shortage and the water supply
i really you know i really started
thinking about how we're in
los angeles and the fault zones and i
think there's actually a fault zone
across the street from our house like
we're lucky that we're on a big
rock but yeah the hillside across from
us
is not the most secure area
and it does sit on a giant fault um
and so sort of assessing that situation
i was like you know i just
i feel like it's important to have
supplies
in case anything were to go wrong you
know i
don't think that it would be as severe i
don't think we'd be cut off from the
world or anything
but it is possible that there could be
a week or two without electricity or
power in the worst case scenario
for that big one that everyone says is
coming yeah so i do
actually have a room in our house that
is dedicated
to meal packages
supplies um cartons of water
and all of this lasts about 75 years so
it's good for a while um and then i also
have you know the
camping cook stoves and gas cubes
and weatherproof matches solar powered
chargers and i kind of have a
supply closet slash room dedicated to
all of that stuff
oh that's great i mean i think that's
it's kids sound crazy to people but i
think that's actually very smart
right well also i might have gotten way
too much too because as i was getting
like okay well it's you and me and then
now we have our dog
and then your mom lives nearby so if
something happened
she'd probably make her way over here to
stay with us and we have a couple
friends that are around the corner
and because they know that i prepare for
things they'll probably be here so like
then i just you know if something goes
wrong i can't handle other people's
[ __ ] so i'm just gonna get enough
supplies
but if we're all here i don't have to
deal with the drama and everybody's back
like oh i love it
yeah it's a good planning that you don't
want to do people's [ __ ]
um well you uh you love halloween right
i do okay so what are you doing this
year
how are you adjusting um
well you know i always have this
tradition that i started where i put the
tree up october 1st
the christmas tree but i decorate it as
a halloween tree so every year
i kind of get new little accessories and
decorations
and i i change the layout ever so
slightly kind of every year and
it keeps getting increasingly larger
every year so
that's that's kind of become a thing in
our household where
october first first thing in the morning
tree goes up and then the rest of the
day is spent decorating the entire tree
in the whole foyer
area of the home and it just becomes a
halloween wonderland
cute very cute um have you
talked through halloween costumes how
far in advance do you work that out
you know when i was younger i was really
into
the costumes but i think i think after
working for
so many years in fashion and then all
the crazy characters and prosthetics and
insanity that i do on set every day yeah
by the
time halloween comes around i kind of
just want to put on pajamas
hang out in pajamas and like that's
that's it like
even today i felt like a big deal to
like brush my hair and put on makeup so
it's the same the fact that i put jeans
on
is wild i know i'm usually just in like
workout clothes because i'm walking the
dog and doing that all day long
well um okay so zoltar is the dog
yeah and this dog is newer
right yes he's eight and a half months
old so he got him february 22nd he came
to came to live with us i guess that's
so
cute what kind of dog is he he's an
otter hound
oh yeah he's massive he looks he's he's
pretty bagged right now he's about 95
pounds
so he still has a bit more growing to do
he hasn't he's not yet hit the puppy
puberty
statement so we'll see because like i
think like
he's still intact as we call like he's
got his balls
so i guess like as he starts to hit
puberty
other dogs that don't have their balls
i just kind of start getting aggressive
towards ones that do
and i did actually for the first time
notice that yesterday when i was walking
him around
the neighborhood there were a couple
dogs that did not that normally were
really happy to see him and suddenly
they were
not not quite friendly a little
insecurity going around
i don't know so yeah i think we're
starting to hit the the puppy puberty
phase so we'll see how that goes
what a journey to be on yeah
i i wonder because uh he has an
instagram account
for people that are curious what are
your tips for running
a dog's instagram account if there are
any i mean
i we do not take it as seriously as i
think
most people do but
we tend to take we're constantly taking
a lot of silly photos of him
anyway oh he's a very photogenic dog
he looks like such a goof and that he's
very goofy
a lot of energy um but then we tend to
just kind of make silly
otter puns and that that's about it i
mean we yeah we're really
not like we don't take anything like
that too seriously we kind of have fun
in it and who knows maybe one day when
we have kids we might be way more
serious about that although
probably i wouldn't let them be on
instagram
true true true um i have a question how
did you
because you and chris just celebrated
four years did i see that on your
instagram yeah congratulations
thank you how did you guys meet
um you know it's sort of interesting and
sad how we met for the first time
um we met
in november 2013
very casually um i was back in new york
at the time because my father
was dying of cancer um it
it started as a parotid adenocarcinoma
he had it for years it metastasized it
stopped and then in the final stages
it mutated into a leptomangel
carcinomatoma
which is a cancer that exists in the
spinal and brain fluid
um so i and i had just finished the face
so i was mainly on the east coast at
that time
and i happened to fly back to los
angeles
for a weekend and one of my best friends
was like hey i live next door to this
hairdresser
he does you know all the hair and makeup
on
this show i think you'd really like it
um
and it'll sort of be like a fun escape
for you because also one of the things
i've never done is i've never been in a
studio audience before so it was sort of
on my bucket list of life
um okay so as i was kind of going
through
all this process and i'd come home to
kind of pack up some more things to move
back east for a while
um i went to the show that happened to
be
talking debt oh wow but i didn't i
didn't meet chris
at that time i sort of it turned out
that i knew
the hairdresser that my friend was
friends with because we'd
coincidentally done a photo shoot
together a few months prior
and he'd also done my hair at runway
shows like way back in the day so we
sort of reconnected
and exchanged numbers and that was that
and then i'm in the audience i'm
watching this show
and it was heartbreaking because it was
the day after
chris's father had passed away and he
still
showed up and he made it through the
show and afterwards i was talking to
sean and chris happened to walk by
and it was just a very brief like hey
you know i'm so sorry
you know i completely understand you
know wishing you and your family
well so nice to meet you and that was it
and we didn't see each other again
didn't talk to each other i mean i
didn't know him
but about eight months later
i get a text message from sean
my friend the hairdresser who worked on
the show and he was like so
you know would you have any interest in
going on a date with chris
and i i didn't really know him i was
like well i'm kind of you know i was
sort of over dating
over everything i was like i don't know
you know i'm kind of
just it's just me and my cat like i
don't know
i'm just doing ready right now yeah like
i sort of just resolved myself
in that i'm gonna be a cat lady
[Laughter]
like i've given up on life totally so i
don't know
like i you know i guess i guess dinner
can't hurt
yeah i guess my cat will handle it
for a second so then i guess
shawn and sean had not asked chris yet
apparently
oh you're funny sean was sort of setting
us up behind the scenes and neither of
us knew and so
and so then i guess sean went to chris
and was like hey so
you know i have this friend i'd really
love to set you up would you have any
interest in going on a date with lydia
and he was like well i mean seriously
would she even have
any interest in like having dinner well
yeah i already asked her she said yes
so that's kind of how our first date
happened and that was probably in
[Music]
july of 2014 oh wow
that we went on our first day but then
our schedules were so
hectic and crazy we had kind of one
day a month and like we kept having to
cancel
and like i thought he wasn't really
interested and he thought i wasn't
really interested
and it's so weird how our relationship
turned out because like
we were both all over the place and
super scattered and then we finally
arranged the third date in october which
was like
worlds away from the first date yeah and
it was in new york we both happened to
be in new york i was there doing
um an indie movie and he was there i
think for the comic con
okay and we had our third date set we're
ready
to go and i'm all dressed up and i'm
about to head out the door
and i got a phone call from eli roth
and he was calling to tell me that i
booked a show
and to pack my bags because in three
days i have to move to charleston
too because it's picked up for the full
season and
we have to go so i was like jumping up
and down
super excited to do the show and then
after
the initial excitement i was like oh
[ __ ] like
okay so then i called chris because i i
just felt
guilty going on a date with him if i
knew i was moving away
to be like i kind of felt so i called
and i was like hey did you leave your
hotel yet
and he was like great she's canceling
again like oh
okay i was like no i don't want to
cancel
but i just you know i wanted to let you
know like i would
love to have dinner with you and i would
love to see you i think you're an
amazing human
but i just booked a show and instead of
going back to california in three days
i'm moving straight to charleston for
seven months so i just
i don't know where you're at in your
life and i'd still love to see you
but i just i wanted to let you know that
you know this is where i'm at like i can
have dinner
but then i'm moving away so i just i
don't know what the future holds really
that is
that's so mature i can't get over it i'm
like that's
so responsible of you to handle it that
way
well it's funny because my sister was
like you're such a weirdo why did you
call him to say i was like because i
felt like it was a lie i really liked
him
but i didn't so respectful
i just like didn't want to have an
amazing day and then be like okay peace
out
yeah you got pranked i'm out of here
so we did we still went to dinner and it
was a wonderful
evening um and we just we sort of we
kept
talking and our relationship really grew
and it was nice it was
it almost felt like an old tiny
old-fashioned
start of something because we we had to
start talking
a lot and that's kind of how the
relationship itself developed we started
talking
you know first it was every couple days
and then every day
and we really got to know each other
over
that time frame where i think a lot of
people nowadays they're so obsessed with
the technology and they're so obsessed
with like the instant gratification
and like yeah it's wrong everybody loves
making out and sex but like
you need to make sure you really like
somebody if you're going to spend time
with them yeah and i think a lot of
people are kind of learning that lesson
now during the lockdown totally totally
the lockdown has really
kind of taken the idea of like immediacy
off the shelf for everyone right that
you have to get to know a person
well or a lot of people are locked in
and realizing oh you're
this like right yeah i actually
don't know you at all yeah or like i
can't stand
being around you for us it was nice that
we really had to build the friendship
and we had to build the bond and we had
to get to know each other
that's very so it was nice and we had
that time period
to just talk and have that relationship
grow and then when we finally
reunited in person again we were just
that much stronger for it
that's very sweet and then i it took off
from there i assume
yeah yeah how sweet that's yeah that is
a very like
old school more traditional romance it's
almost like
it's like you were away at war and he
was writing letters to you or something
exactly
yes yeah and it was nice too because it
wasn't just over text
it was yeah we actually had phone calls
which
was refreshing and really nice where
he wasn't big into texting and i'm also
a terrible texter
so yeah it's embarrassing like if i
don't instantly respond
then my add probably kicked in and i
forgot and i'll never get
i fully fully relate to that yeah that's
so sweet okay we're gonna take one last
break when we get back
a couple more questions and then twitter
has some questions for you so we'll be
right back
[Music]
okay lydia before we get into some
twitter questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions ask every single guest
that is on the podcast
and the first the first question is who
alive or dead
would you most like to throw cold
spaghetti at
oh called spaghetti at um
i i mean
is it yeah i feel like there's a lot of
people right now that i'm like
100 i mean i normally don't get
political but
i mean i wouldn't mind throwing it at
donald trump yes
you are not alone don't worry that is
that is the common answer
and i i don't deny uh
that urge or impulse i think it's spot
on
yeah um okay the other question i ask
every single guest is to tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story
or like close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases or
some combination of those
so for instance mine is college
jogging front lawn um
okay oh so you mean like literal pants
[ __ ] yeah or any sort of like
any sort of like it's just like you get
scared and it's like
any sort of like bathroom emergency
experience oh okay um
i mean i just had to pee really bad but
it was when chris and i were still
dating and it would have been
san francisco okay here
desperate yep yep that paints a picture
that all of us can relate to especially
when you're dating that's the worst
yeah it was so awful i will never forget
it and he still sometimes brings it up
as a joke where
we i like i i drink a lot of water
um like i literally wearing over a
gallon of water a day
and very jealous he was on his comedy
tour and i visited to go see some of the
shows we're in san francisco
and we're like walking up here and
visiting all these like cool little
knick-knack places and shops and there's
one sort of like toy museum
up there on one of the piers and we also
went on some
boats and you know if people in san
francisco are going to think i'm
terrible because i can't tell you what
everything is
but after hours of just walking around
and doing all this stuff
and i kept trying to be like this is so
fun this is so fun and like you're
holding it you're holding it you're
holding it and then finally like
i was on the brink of tears and i was
like i think i'm gonna pee my pants yeah
i've been there i've been there where
you think that you have a superpower
that you could potentially hold it
forever and like maybe it'll just
like reintroduce itself into your system
yeah yeah and suddenly you're like i
don't have that superpower
and this is so embarrassing because like
i actually gets really close that i'm
like
i'm trying to restroom because it's so
bad
now i'm gonna do irreversible damage to
my urinary tract if i
don't get to a facility thankfully i did
not be my parents
but a few phew okay
um we have a couple twitter questions
for you here someone wants to know what
is your favorite scary movie no pun
intended
you know that for me is
weirdly as a true horror fan the one
question that i have the most
trouble with because i'm sure such a
horror fanatic
and it's the one area that i truly kind
of geek out over where i'm like well
what genre or subgenre
scientific the naturalistic the
spiritual is it
for torture porn slasher werewolves
vampires
paranormal and then what where is it
from what region is it korean is it
japanese is it australian is it english
is it spanish is it colombia so
i i honestly break it down
into so many categories in my brain
wow i would have to
look through every single section of
that to
decipher okay i enjoy i mean i literally
watch
every single horror movie as it comes
out whether
it's well-known and promoted or some
obscure indie film
anything that pops up on itunes amazon
netflix
shutter i'm on it it's pretty much all i
watch
all day every day amazing
okay how about this is there one
uh movie that comes to mind that if they
remade it you would
die to be cast in pun intended
oh you know i'm not
typically big on the remakes
i love to see original concepts
um like you know if someone i know that
they re
made the original evil dead and it was
fun
but like to me that series is sort of
perfect and shouldn't
be touched and that's the equivalent of
the princess bride and for
to me that whole sort of three set right
there
um like evil dead body belong to an army
of darkness
uh i mean there's so many
films that i i love i mean in the new
horror i know trying to busan is getting
remade okay these are i'm not a horror
person so
all of these words are a different
language to me but i love
hearing how complex this genre is
because
you know someone from the outside just
goes ah [ __ ]
it all goes right like people think it's
about like
jump scares and slasher
and gore but to me i love i love the
atmosphere that gets
created and films that are effectively
creepy and really draw you in and it's a
form of escapism because you know
that it's not real to a degree but it's
so
it's just so fascinating and so fun to
me
well here's this kind of goes in line
with that someone asked uh
if you could make a horror movie about a
reality show
what would you pick oh
um you know there has been something
that i was
working on developing but i think i
think there was a series that was done
um by the same person that created black
mirror years ago
um kind of about a reality show the
zombie apocalypse hits
um but i sort of thought something like
you know
love island and then the zombie
apocalypse where it's like
you know yeah and they think they're all
good but then
what happens if a zombie gets washed
ashore on the beach and then all hell
breaks loose
um this is a great premise make this
movie please
i think that's fantastic
okay last question before we wrap things
up
uh if all toys came to life and became
evil
how many dolls do you think you could
take on and beat up
oh i mean i think i i think i could do
pretty well
um you know i do before my accident a
year and a half ago i did do a lot of
hand combat fighting and
and special training for firearms wow i
i think
i could i'm a little rusty but i think i
could handle my own
either that or i'd probably join in on
the fun and switch sides and be totally
evil i don't know
i might have the evil doll sanctuaries
right right right you have options you
have options in this fantasy
um lydia this has been so fun
before we wrap up completely usually
when we do the podcast in person
we have um a personalized fortune cookie
that we give to our guest
for making time for us but because we're
doing this remotely we have a digital
fortune cookie that i think
melissa i think melissa emailed it to
you
oh this is so funny and actually
something that i i could
elaborate on yes please do if you'd like
to read your fortune out loud for
everyone yes
it says your venture in describing dog
farts in wine lingo
may be a prosperous albeit smelly road
to stay on
yes and that is um that's really funny
because i haven't announced this yet
but as you earlier you mentioned the her
strict home
and during the lockdown and the
quarantine chris and i have sort of been
dabbling in and experimenting with
fragrances and also with bees
um so we're sort of considering we we
had an infestation of bees
so we got saved and removed and taken
elsewhere but we we have an excessive
amount of honey right now
and we're looking into apiaries and
possibly getting bees and making her
sweet honey
um but in addition to that
um i've sort of been torturing him with
essential oils and
smells and things because when i put
that out
i wanted to hear what people had to say
because
i actually created a candle and i'm
waiting for the final product to arrive
any day now um the first of many that
we're going
to launch for the hershberg home
collection
and it's called dog farts
um where can i get this uh we will send
you one
absolutely not smell like dog farts okay
thank god
disclaimer at the bottom where you light
in case of canine flatulence
oh i love this idea that's fantastic
i kept coming at him and throwing the
oils in his face and being like what
about this one what about this one i
like these scents mixed together and
what if i add
mahogany or take mahogany away can you
smell the difference and
so i'm really proud of the final product
oh my gosh that's such a great idea the
label
and i put a lot of effort into it and
thankfully he put up with all these like
odorous things happening around now
because zoltar is a big dog and when he
has a gas it is
disgusting he's good at what he does
it is loud like wow
that's fantastic oh i'm so excited
i'm glad to hear that like very
innovative business is coming out of
this bizarre quarantine time
yes we've stayed creative
the official first candle and yeah
probably in the next few days we're kind
of waiting for the shipment to arrive
and all these candles that we made
uh amazing amazing amazing lydia this
has been
so fun uh for people that don't know
can you let them know where to find you
and everything that you're up to
including but not limited to dog farts
etc yes
um i'm lydia hirst i'm on twitter and
instagram
at lydia hearst um and yeah i'm i'm
around i don't post that much but i
always pop
up now and again and yeah like i said
eventually we're probably launching the
etsy store
and linking it into the id10t page and
maybe making a horseback home site
um oh that's pbd right now first we just
gotta get the candles in
um and yeah i have the lifetime movie
that's going to be premiering on the
19th and a lot of other fun things
coming out soon
awesome well this is so fun go check out
everything she's up to you guys
psycho sister-in-law included uh
and you know dog farts is the beginning
of really great things i
feel in my bones yes it is thank you
again for being here lydia
and we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep deep not too
deep
with christ not too deep is a production
of grace helbig incorporated producer
melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music